taking action but some action take
action taking action taking action take
advantage take action when into pursuing
different passions with eyes wide open
meaning knowing because my focus was
split I probably wouldn't be getting
very far in any of them but I made a
conscious choice that I just wanted to
experience them I wanted to understand
them from the inside out I spent so much
time thinking in my mind is this the
right choice for me is this the right
career for me should I try and build a
business around this and I said that's
such a dumb way to go around it like you
should just engage an experience and
actually get your foot in the industry
that can inform whether or not you
should move ahead about someone who's
stuck or struggling what would you tell
them stuck or struggling is is typically
someone who is more engaged in their
thoughts than actually taking action so
it's a really interesting subtle shift
but if you catch yourself complaining
like oh I'm so stuck and let stop yeah
write an email make a call take a step
and the more you actually do that and
catch yourself we actually sorry this is
me a DD my toes are exactly that color
awesome
yes love it but it is it's really a
practice of checking in with yourself
you gotta check yourself before you
wreck yourself like stop complaining
stop talking yourself in your head and
do something then a dominating desire
plan or purpose which is backed by that
State of Mind known as faith has taken
over to the subconscious section of the
mind of acting upon immediately I don't
know for sure ladies and gentlemen but I
suspect if there's a relatively small
number of people in the world any one
time who understand the principle of
faith who really understands it to know
how to apply and even if you do
understand it if you don't back it up
with action and make it a part of your
habit life you might just as well not
understand it because faith without
deeds is this faith without action is
dead faith without the absolute positive
belief is dead I don't know how you're
going to get any results through
believing unless you
some action back of that belief the
incidental if you tell your mind often
enough that you have faith in anything
the time will come when your
subconscious minds really accept that
even if you tell your mind off enough
that you have faith in yourself as you
ever thought about a nice thing it would
be if you had such complete faith in
yourself that you wouldn't hesitate to
undertake anything you want to do in
life have you ever thought what that
what a benefit that would be to you I
want to talk about risk as a guiding
principle life shrinks and life expands
in direct proportion to your willingness
to assume risk yeah I like I've made
some really stupid decisions in my
career for my entire career on a broad
plane they've all worked out
every time I've quit my jobs which I've
done every time I've had a job
people that I trust most that freak
people that I love all advise against it
my dad told me not to move to New York
City because it was such a risk
and every time I every time I took these
bigger risks the opportunity for a
larger payout was always there life is
like this super temporary mega fragile
thing you only get like a nugget of time
to really pursue the things you care
about
and like I'm thirty thirty and my rule
is that the right time is always right
now to put a little meat on these bones
this new company that I don't really
talk about this new company is the
biggest risk I've ever taken I took five
years of my life to build my advertising
career and I made like a lot of money
I've been doing really great look at my
youtube channel go all the way back the
last branded content thing you'll see
was in February of 2014 I ditched it all
to pursue something I knew nothing about
this huge risk and I did it at a time
when my wife was pregnant
and there was all of this vulnerability
and all the scariness in my life and
even now at 33 my dad's at 34 my dad
said Casey that's crazy you've got a
good thing don't let it go but I know
that like someday I won't be able to do
this I know that the time is now the
time the right time is always now so I
had to do it that's how I feel about
risk in Jeff
Merl and that's what the struggle has
always been for me it's like identifying
risk identifying fear and then just
smashing through it because a fear is
looking back and wishing that I had done
these things the most dangerous thing
you can do in your career the most
dangerous thing you can do in life is
play it safe I read this book because I
was in disbelief as people here's the
strategy for success of the secret right
go into your house and go quiet room and
you close the lights draw the shades and
sit on a couch and visualize a big fat
check twenty-five G's thousand bucks
u.s. okay with your name on it and I
want you to imagine that check and just
make that check go bigger in your mind
and make it real more real and just put
it out into the ether of the universe
and the law of attraction will take hold
just think about it oh great hello if
that's your strategy for success the
only hit will show up in your mailbox is
not the check it's a freaking eviction
notice from your landlord
they'll be towing away your car your
wife your husband all for the next-door
neighbor and you'll be still saying
where's the check where's the check with
okay the secret is a load of crap okay
do I believe in manifestation yeah damn
straight I do but you got to take action
I'm one of those unfortunate people I
tried it I really do I tried it I read
the book so let me try you know so I
said I'd try to pray for the check never
came but I went out and started taking
action guess what the check came with
extra couple of zeros you have to
actually show up every day and inch
yourself forward toward these streams
and not only show up every day and once
in a while into yourself I mean every
day you have to actually take an action
that moves you forward not just research
not just thinking look the power of an
intention is great but without any
initiative it's dead right a dream is
great but without any movement it's dead
you have to be moving towards everyday
you can send an email every day you can
make a call every day you can write
something every day you can create
thing every day you can contribute
something every day but it has to be
daily otherwise it will never become
actualized the highest performers in the
world didn't get there because they were
lucky they worked at it longer than
everyone else they had a better work
ethic and something that necessarily
always worked harder they work smarter
because they were doing the research
they were taking the time to visualize
how they would be distinct different how
they would survive the tough times they
really kept at it keep every single day
momentum going and if you don't do that
there's no chance
you cannot lose by taking action you can
only lose by not taking action I think
the great majority of people surrounded
by the greatest opportunities in the
best country in the history of man on
earth who don't succeed are people who
are on the island always got a reason
for not taking action and if you have
delay taking action repeatedly over and
over again you develop the habit of
never taking action you get the result
that habit of procrastinating and
holding back and so on it's never been
better to be an entrepreneur like right
now right this second is the greatest
there's massive disruption I promise you
because I spent a lot of time with
everybody in corporate America the big
companies are so slow and stupid it's
almost unbearable right so that's great
for us if we don't have money and we've
got time right and so that's great and
and the cost of entry is easy there's so
many people that are envious of the
lucky things that happen to me investing
in like uber and Birchbox and Twitter
and all those things that now everybody
in their 30s to 60s that has any level
of money is chasing any kid in a hoodie
with an idea and giving them money to
invest in their startup because
everybody's looking for their exit right
so on top of the fact that the internet
is hitting maturity and every users on a
smartphone and blah blah blah and we're
at scale on top of that in parallel
there's a float of dumb money chasing it
and looking it to give it to anybody
they can which is your opportunity so we
need to take advantage of that and
actually if you think you're ready
you should literally start your company
right now because I'm sure it's
important to finish this class and
whatever but tomorrow the market can
collapse and you'll miss this
opportunity literally right now on a
half-ass idea right
like two or three connections from like
your parents or professors or emailing
me and I interview somebody you can
literally raise a million dollars on
your own idea but we need to like want
like I want everybody understand that
all it takes is something crazy like a
terrorist attack or some Bank full of
[ __ ] breaking or like tomorrow that can
go away and so like I think it's super
important for everybody understand that
if you're itching I think you should
start tomorrow because the money's there
and you're gonna need the money because
this happens all the time like everybody
that looked like you in 2008-9 they went
got jobs everybody looked like you in
two thousand two and three after the
first bubble they went and got jobs so
if you're true entrepreneur if you're
sitting here like no I'm entrepreneur
I'm not just in the class you need to
seriously concentrate on where we are at
this exact moment in the market and
recognize how fruitful it is for you how
much of an advantage you have you may
want to seriously consider and take
advantage of it because I could really
go away in a second and then you've got
a way to like if it collapses tomorrow
if there's a bubble burst you're gonna
have to wait three to five years to get
your shot when bubbles bursts no kid
with an idea gets dead got it it's a
good one take action so many people talk
about doing something or say what if
they don't actually get up and do it
taking action is really really important
in 1998 when I was working for another
company I was running an airing of
whether to set up my own business I
didn't have a lot of money but I decided
to take action I decided to do it but I
did it in a very planned way I knew
exactly what I was going to do I knew
exactly what I wanted to achieve but the
most important thing I took action
within two or three years I was a
millionaire again probably the best
thing that I ever did so taking action
is absolutely vital but twenty years ago
in the movies rules are very clearly
defined they provided the security of
your stardom in a sense if you had been
successfully playing an angry young man
you'd pretty much be angry and young for
the rest of your life if you've been a
police inspector in three movies odds
were
you'd be in the next 33 - they supplied
two female actresses also wives or wives
seductresses were seductresses
mother-in-law's were mother-in-law's and
so on and so forth
few actors would have willingly switched
from romantic heroes to obsessively
violent lovers I took the leap not
because I was particularly brave but
because a very dear director friend of
mine sat me down and told me I was
extremely ugly and being ugly
necessarily meant I know now I know and
being ugly necessarily meant I do bad
guy roles I wasn't the romantic hero
types he said actually he used the words
that my face was not chocolate enough so
I started to eat a lot of chocolate and
while waiting for it to take effect I
jumped into bad guy roles there means
fair in Hindi and everyone always tells
you at speeches like this that you ought
to be brave so I'm not going to bore you
with that idea instead let me tell you
this being brave means being scared all
the way to the party yeah I'm sorry if
that word is being very scared all the
way to the body but getting there but
getting there all the same and doing the
funky chicken in front of all your
teenage kids friends anyway let me just
add on on behalf of all the fathers of
the world who have embarrassed the kids
by doing this it takes a lot of bravery
resolve and grit to do it so just do it
don't let your fears become boxes that
enclose you open them out feel them and
turn them into the greatest courage you
are capable of I promise you nothing
will go wrong but if you live by your
fears everything that can pass possibly
go wrong will go wrong and you won't
even have done the funky duty I was on
the train from Manchester to London and
it came just came
had something like that ever happen to
you before yes truthfully I mean other
ideas have just come to me because I
think if you're a writer and that's what
you spend a huge amount of time doing
you do ideas do come to you but nothing
had ever come so with such a I had this
I thought I'd love to write that and
when I got off the train I went straight
home and I started writing thank you
guys so much for watching I'm curious to
know what you do to take action what do
you do when you're in a funk and how do
you get yourself out of it please share
in the comments below I think it'll be
really helpful to everybody else
watching to kind of learn from you as
well in your experiences
my personal goal on the YouTube channel
is to hit a million subscribers so
anything you could do to help me share
this video get it out there spread the
message I'd really really really
appreciate it thank you guys so much for
watching and T need to believe and I'll
see you soon